so I actually wrote this song I was
dreaming and it came out of a dream and
it was at a time in my life where I felt
sort of unappreciated and a little sorry
for myself for whatever reason and or
felt the burden of my vocation and then
I thought about I was sitting there
thinking about William Blake and I
thought William Blake who was such it
was are an artist a visionary a an
activist so many things a philosopher he
gave us he left us so much work he was
giving beautiful work in his own time
but because of the Industrial Revolution
he was completely trampled almost
completely forgotten and died in poverty
but he did his work he was on his
deathbed still drawing still projecting
angels and he maintained his vision as a
vision no matter how much strife he was
confronted with so wrote this little
song
[Music]
in my black in year
was so disposed toward a mission
unclear
pole to pole badge in Bremen to my ear
compare the simple code
and road was paved
and road was gist of road
and my blankie in-year search the world
for schism
existence
this night as I envisioned
whose and trim from track to track
down to the soul
is paved
Gold
this gist
[Music]
[Music]
puts a trim from track to track
down to the soul
one road
[Music]
miss Geist
[Music]
my blacken year
Jim tation
his
just a shallow spear
cowardice
brace yourself for bitter flak
for a life divine
boring the riches
never shall why
Cheers goodbye
a stitched in
the Blakey and
so throw up you stupid blue
grace
fear
boy will
Oh despair
in my Blakey here so throw out your
stupid
embrace of achoo fear
[Music]
all despair
Blakey here
my Blakey year
mercy hath a human heart
pity but you may fix
the human before
if you man dress
Mircea pity a peace and love
for a night distress
Shelly
brace
merci chéri
Percy Shelley
aha
aha
aha
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]